[Music]
life on the island isn't easy and it's
not a place where you come to get rich
but it's
a better lifestyle
so it's a happier lifestyle
with so few people on the island
everybody has to have multiple jobs to
keep the island afloat with everybody
else
welcome to north frontal z a small
remote island off the northern reaches
of scotland home to around 50 people two
lighthouses
an airport
some sheep
cattle and a few seals
and that's about it
not much of a labor force
so while on the mainland you might have
one maybe two jobs up here it's more
like six or seven
meet sarah moore my name's sarah moore
i've got quite a few jobs in ireland i'm
home carer
clerk to the community council i work at
the airfield
baggage handler and firefighter i've got
a flock of sheep
and i'm the postie on the island really
the job is being an islander which is
just mucking in and helping with various
bits and pieces and no two days ever the
same i could be helping with cattle one
day and fixing our roof the other day
and
it's whatever the the islanders need
help but you just muck in
logan 727 northrops your windows 184
degrees safety is our number one
priority and not always it
but
thankfully we've never had an emergency
so hopefully keep it that way
[Music]
i moved to the island about three and a
half years ago fedenburg i wasn't
enjoying life there and there's just so
many people and it's you you didn't care
anybody you're completely anonymous it's
quite a lonely place
up here my conference has gained
massively because people they come along
they teach you the skills that you need
i certainly never had sheep at edinburgh
hello hello
most people didn't quite understand that
when i say i've got like six jobs it's
not six full-time jobs i mean it starts
off i'm working you know 24 hours a day
there's far more job satisfaction at the
end of the day you can see you've
actually accomplished something as
opposed to just you know done the same
old thing day and day
how many houses do you have to live at i
think it's something like 25 houses in
the island that i delivered to how does
it take you
a few hours it depends on the amount of
posts we get
this island's really magical i mean it's
completely unique in its own way you're
never going to find a place like this
where you can just come up and live the
way you're supposed to live you know
we're ruled by the weather as opposed to
the clock and i have no plans to go
anywhere i'm setting up roots and i'm
going to be here till i die
[Music]
you